be sure to follow me on instagram there
you can hang out with me and talk to me
directly
what's going on guys this is Rob and in
this video I wanted to talk about the
idea of Marvel 2099 on Disney Plus right
because I think it would work
exceedingly well like with all the stuff
that they're doing so uh what's Marvel
2099 right like of what use would we be
as a comic-book youtube channel that
explains things if we were like this
would be a great idea thanks for
watching guys peace
I feel terrible it'd be a terrible
example of comics explain um so Marvel
2099 was an imprint that was launched in
1992 and ran for about six years to 1998
I'll explain why here in a second but um
it was a it was a super popular concept
when it first popped up right because it
really came out of like - spider-man
2099 but there were a few things that
sort of landed this right so back in
1987 Marvel had an editor-in-chief that
came on board who I think was
editor-in-chief for about seven years
and so in 1994 named uh Tom DeFalco and
Tom DeFalco and made his bones in the
comic book landscape by orchestrating
some pretty significant deals right I
mean he's the one that orchestrated the
deal between Hasbro slash GI Joe and
Marvel Comics which is why you got like
GI Joe comics coming out of Marvel back
in the 1980s he was really really big
and that fell on that on that front not
to mention he had his hand in some
pretty significant stories over the
years and so the result was that in 92
where he was less heavy-handed than Jim
shooter and so far as Jim shooter had
this attitude as editor-in-chief like if
your stories are late you're fired in
terms of writing award or or artist work
this is the direction that Marvel's
going in if you're on board with it
awesome you can stay if not you're fired
the guy was pretty heavy-handed DeFalco
was a lot less heavy-handed right he was
almost like this total 180 this paradigm
shift away from what what Jim shooter
had done and it was one of these things
where it was kind of like just let's
explore some ideas unless you see what
happens you know whatever whatever goes
on goes on um and the result was that in
92 Marvel ended up launching Marvel 2099
and this really again came out of ugly
of the amazing spider-man and this was
this was really just like the
introduction of Miguel O'Hara
and for the most part it was hugely
popular with with spider-man because
it's spider-man right I mean pretty much
anything spider-man related will sell
and marvel comics even if it's not the
most popular among like the the super
hardcore hipster comic fans or
what-have-you
for the most part among the casual kind
of book buying audio
it's popular it'll always do us reason
why he's the face of the company and so
with with Miguel O'Hara being introduced
he was different for Peter Parker
insofar as Miguel O'Hara actually worked
for the company that he that he
basically fought against Triton in the
year 2099 it was really more this idea
that like corporations rule the world
right and alchemax was the biggest out
of all of them and so Miguel O'Hara
worked for alchemax but at the same time
work to try to bring it down right so
it's like if Peter Parker worked for
work for the Daily Bugle and was trying
to like bring the company down at the
same time right so um because of that
like Marvel ended up launching a handful
of other imprint so I guess a handful of
other titles that came after that right
so we started getting things like like
uh I think it was ravage which was
written by Stanley I'm pretty sure it
was um we got the Incredible Hulk we
ended up getting stories later on like
dr. doom dr. doom was actually designed
to shift the the Marvel 2099 2099
universe from where it was - you know -
to like a different take right so that's
why they put ad at the end of all the
stories that came after dr. doom but
there were a lot of really cool concepts
that came out of it but but really the
biggest reason why it works so well is
because it wasn't really grounded in
anything right it was just kind of out
there it was it really tight anything
we're just sort of out there right now
more recently in more recent years
Marvel is basically solidified that like
it's the absolute future of the main
Marvel Universe right like the year 2099
that's the future like we will have we
will past 2099 and go forward from there
into twenty one hundred and twenty three
hundred and the year three thousand and
so on and so forth but everything that
transpires and the 2099 continuity will
happen right there's no getting around
that there's no deviating that it's not
an alternate reality it's not Days of
Future past or anything like that it's
the absolute future um but at the time
that it was being made it was basically
like this is a potential future that
exists out there and we may or may not
see it and so seeing possible futures
from Marvel was exceedingly popular at
the time um and so with the other you
know other iterations or characters that
we got Punisher and a lot of those guys
it sold pretty well the issue with this
is that by the time you got know they
come and bust in the mid-1990s Marvel
ended up shutting it down for you or at
least by 1988 Marvel ended up shutting
it down and the way this played out
again is is is we talk about the comic
bust of the 1990s and so far as if you
were buying comics and and trying to
trade comics before 1971 then
which is kind of like who knows how much
your comics worth right it's worth
whatever your local retailer will whilst
will give it you know give you forth
based on how many people are coming in
and ask for you asking for the comic
right so if nobody's coming in and
asking for DC showcase number four which
was the first appearance of the flash
Barry Allen then you're gonna get
pennies for it whereas if people are
coming in all the time and trying to get
their hands on it well then it's gonna
be worth a whole lot more now the reason
why I say nineteen seventy one is
because that's when the Overstreet price
guide was invented and that was
basically how much your comic was worth
on a national scale right so you had a
bargaining chip you could go into you're
coming with retailer and you could say
I've got DC showcase number four and and
according to the Overstreet price guide
it's worth like a thousand bucks and
your retailer would say I'm gonna give
you five hundred and it's like I'll just
take my business elsewhere I'll write to
some publisher out there somewhere in
some company or some some other state
and I'll tell them that I have this
comic and take pictures and send it to
him I guess so that was a readily
available technology of the time if it
was I'd never really familiarize myself
with photography in the 1970s um and
then in turn basically kind of go back
and forth through snail mail and
ultimately sell the comic right so your
retail that retail is a that turned you
down couldn't miss out the reason why
this matters is because what it meant
was that people sort of buying up a
whole bunch of different comic right
like comics that were rare or comments
that were significant we're suddenly
worth a whole lot of money right so you
get into like you know 1987 with the
Dark Knight Returns huge comic book
right I mean it's like the the brief is
more not really removed with like a
dystopian future belonging to Batman
everybody bought those right you get
x-force number one in 1991 huge deal 91
or 92 is it's a huge deal um x-men vol 2
issue number one in 1992 huge deal right
so it sells like gangbusters I think
that was 91 but anyway it sounds like
gang busters just a great big huge deal
because they're number ones they're
comics of significance different things
like that
the death of Superman another really
good example what this basically meant
was because retailers didn't tell Marvel
or DC the fact that that people were
buying multiple copies of issue number
ones and all they did was say we sold a
million copies of x-men vol 2 issue
number one over the course of the last
three months then all Marvel and DC saw
were overall sales and so as a result of
coming
fans as well as collectors going in and
just buying up a ton of comics marveling
deceive not getting all the information
they needed oversaturated the market and
that basically led to comics being worth
nothing right it's the red diamond
example that I use red diamonds as far
as I'm aware don't exist mean they do I
don't know but it seems like something
that would be exceedingly rare right so
if you're walking down the road you find
the red diamond it's worth a ton of
money until some scuba diver
you know enters some cave somewhere and
finds a wall full of red diamonds and
suddenly yours is worth a whole lot less
and that's basically what happened with
comics and so as a result of that Marvel
in the mid-1990s was just like if it's
not overly popular if it's not selling
extent he exceedingly well cut it get
rid of it either that or license it out
to event publications from Jimmy palmy
Adi and Joe Quesada and so model 2099
was one of those publications where they
were just like it's not so like it's not
really performing that well we've tried
to reshuffle it we've tried to make it
work
one of the big mistakes that Marvel made
is they actually fired Jovi cavaliere
Joey Cavaliere was the the editor in
chief I'm sorry interim chief the editor
of Marvel 2099 at the time and was
hugely respected in the comic-book
community right because he made his
bones back in the 1980s in 1982 to 1986
riding on Detective Comics 521 to 580 I
think 560 something like that anyway he
wrote Detective Comics for a number of
issues and they were actually backup
features that he was writing with green
arrow that was in Detective Comics he
wrote Huntress issues one through 119
I'm sorry 1 through 19 from 1989 1990
right so like he had a hue he had a
pretty significant involvement over the
course of comics not to mention all the
other titles that he was involved in so
model firing him was a huge deal because
like at the time he had like Peter David
you had Warren Ellis people like that
who were huge riders in the comic book
community and who quit right so
basically because Marvel fired the
editor who was well respected by the
writers and artists of the community
pretty much all the writers and artists
quit and that helped to even further
sync Marvel 2099 and so ultimately in
1998 the whole imprint went belly-up now
in recent years Marvel has referenced it
really Miguel O'Hara spider-man 2099
more than anybody else um but
occasionally you see characters right so
you'll read exiles you read the world
tour story arc from actually I think I
took a took place after house of M where
the exiles this multiverse whole
superhero team actually
travels from one universe to the next so
they end up in like the future imperfect
universe where the maestro fork rules
everything and they also end up stopping
and the be Marvel 2099 universe and
actually not facing off against Hulk
2099 which is a really really cool idea
but but nonetheless um with regards to
this this this print this imprint this
this this thing when it does you know in
terms of putting it on Disney Plus kind
of moving into the you know the meat and
potatoes in this discussion what it does
in terms of putting it on Disney Plus is
it focuses on this idea of Disney
essentially taking a series of stories
involving the characters they love and
almost kind of making it what if right
because again back when it first popped
up in 92
Marvel was just like this is some
possible future that exists out there
nothing may come of it but it's just
some possible future that exists out
there and that was basically yeah bring
it into to to the modern era right like
bring it in into Disney Plus and they
could basically say like you get Iron
Man 2099 you get the Incredible Hulk
2099 Captain America 2099 these are not
the absolute characters that you know
they're just a possible future that you
could see right and they could tie it
into the what-ifs
right I mean you get like what if
infinity war or Avengers in game or a
combination of both which I think
they're doing you get Marvel 2099 which
is the future of that particular
storyline right yeah any number of
things could come out of that in Marvel
Comics we got things like x-men 2099
right so the issue that you have with
that is you can only really do that once
the characters are introduced right
because it would seem almost backwards
right like you bring the x-man into on
to Disney Plus into the 2099 see a TV
series and then in turn you roll them
into the movie people are going to
expect that whatever they see in the
movie is going to lead to 2099 which may
not necessarily be the case right so you
don't really want to build things
backward you want to build things going
forward and so as a result of that you
know things like Fantastic Four like we
saw in the comics things like x-men like
we saw in the comics I would hold off on
those but in terms of seeing the
characters that we have seen at the
moment the core Avengers more or less
Black Widow different characters like
that um you could basically say 2090 not
because remember that that 2099 version
of those characters is not the same as
the main Marvel Universe version now
they have crossed over over the years
and in fact I think Doctor Doom and
Miguel O'Hara are the only two
characters from the 2099 universe that
actually crossed over and met there
parts and the main Marvel Universe right
so basically travel to the past and and
met like their modern-day versions I
think that's the only time that ever
really happened but uh but nonetheless
you know it offers some pretty cool
opportunity in terms of showing us these
are we haven't really seen before
because that's one of the big things of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe relaxed at
the moment and while I do love what
they've done when you sort of take away
and it rocks when you sort of step back
and and stop allowing yourself to be
carried away by all the great movies
that we've seen and you kind of look at
the entirety of the MCU for what it is
we've got the Avengers and we've got two
guardians of the galaxy and that's
basically yeah right and you got a few
cameos here and there there's very
little that's actually been done in
terms of building up the world of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe right like we
don't have anything to do with the x-men
of course that explains itself because
of the whole situation with Fox and
those characters same thing with the
Fantastic Four spider-man's back into
Sony now so who the heck knows how
that's gonna turn out but in terms of
bringing in groups like like I don't
know like factor three and bringing in
groups like I don't know like squadron
supreme basically like Marvel's version
of the Justice League Hyperion and and
those characters you know bringing in
these various groups like the Shiar
Empire which as far as I'm aware I guess
as part of the x-men from Fox so Marvel
probably could have done that but like
various Avengers villains right so
giving us the actual Mandarin and the
ten rings we're gonna see that in
shang-chi but it would have been nice to
see an Iron Man because the Mandarin is
a core Iron Man villain different things
like that they haven't really built up a
whole lot of that stuff and Doctor
Strange too we're gonna see him and
Scarlet Witch exploring the multiverse
so that's cool to see that multiversal
you know expansion going on probably the
introduction of characters like
nightmare probably seeing a little bit
more of Dormammu learning about him
hopefully fingers crossed we get to
learn about zom we tell you something
Dom is so powerful it's like the one
thing Doctor Strange is afraid of right
like if zom shows up here like we're all
gonna die and he's not wrong like if
it's zom is crazy powerful we've
actually got a video on if you guys want
to check it out
I'll have my editor put it down in the
description but there really isn't a
whole lot of building going on there in
terms of you know the the president
what's going on right now in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe as well as what's
going on outside of Earth in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe just whatever we seen
in guardians of the galaxy and
essentially everything has been
earth-based which makes sense because
they're essentially just now starting
out right I mean when you look at the
Marvel Cinematic Universe in relation to
everything while comics has to offer
we've hardly even stepped out
door we've got our hand on the doorknob
that's all we've really done so far when
you consider the vast amount of stuff
that's out there and the sheer number of
story arcs that they could do there's a
lot to cover so um I think taking
something like 2099 and leaving it out
of the movies right not really throwing
it in the movies and watching themselves
into an absolute future but instead
throwing it on a Disney Plus giving
people even more of an incentive to go
and get it like they really need it and
then in turn you know just kind of
giving us a possible future based on the
characters that we know I think it's a
genius idea I think it's a really really
smart idea and I think it wouldn't work
I would certainly watch it now this
really sort of I guess really relies on
the fact that it's well written the fact
that that the the TV show is produced in
an adequate way and then it doesn't feel
cheap if it ends up feeling like some
really crappy you know cheap thing
that's got a budget of you know 50 bucks
and pizzas for everybody who shows up
then like it sucks and nobody wants to
see that nobody read one is nobody won't
want to watch that because we just feel
so low quality but uh but again you know
it's just it's one of the possibilities
that are out there and there's a lot of
things you can do with it and it's kind
of funny because the reason why all this
comes on is probably the question want
people are asking you is why even talk
about this in the first place the reason
why all this really seems to come on is
because of the fact that Marvel's doing
a whole bunch of 2099 one-shots
from late November going in you know
going all throughout December and and it
kind of begs the question why like what
fans are out there are clamoring for the
return of 2099 no one's really asking
for that maybe more Miguel O'Hara you
know I mean we've saw him from
spider-man into the spider-verse so just
on that alone really begs more you know
from from the character regarding you
know his comic book appearances but I
don't really hear anybody clamoring for
the return of Hulk 2099 or dr. doom 2099
or or the Avengers or the x-men or or
Fantastic Four or anything like that
I don't really hear anybody asking for
that stuff or requesting the the return
of those things and so because that it's
like why in the world would they do that
and I think they're doing it because
they're toying with the idea see how it
performs a couple the form and see what
an author is a fan base there and if
there is they can in turn roll it over
and put it on a Disney Plus I think it's
kind of what they're looking at at the
moment as far as I'm aware they haven't
announced it they haven't said they're
gonna do anything with it but I have a
feeling that was something like this
that's the only reason it seems to make
sense either that or they just want to
see what happens they're doing it for
the sake of doing it which is entirely
well who knows but without these sub
guys we're gonna go and bring this video
to an end if you I'm new here too
comments explained to make sure you guys
with the sub button to become part of
the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later
[Music]
you